when you first arrived in LA you were
huge we're just starting out you came
with a friend and you guys were like a
lot of us you first show up and you
don't have a lot of money yeah and
everyone has different degrees like some
of us show up with a little something
you showed up in LA when you want to get
started this business with pretty much
nothing is that right yeah we had a
little chunk of money that we put down
on an apartment and literally it left us
with $40 and so we we weren't sure we
were waiting for checks to come in from
residuals from Canada but you know we
literally made $40 last for about two
weeks so whenever I would get invited
out for a dinner date I'd ask if I could
bring a friend and do a double date and
we'd bring big bags and shove the bread
and the bags for breakfast the next day
and then we'd go to Washington Mutual
and they had these little free mini
muffins and coffee and we pretend to
check out our bank account that we
didn't even have you would steal muffins
from a bank it's not stealing they were
free yeah there's a big moment I see a
bank
it's Ackerman again get her I don't know
there's the things you do when you're
just trying to make things you gotta eat
ramen noodles for for a dollar my god
yeah that is the that is fent ramen
noodles I ate nothing but ramen noodles
for most of college yeah and I loved it
I could make it tuna I can make I still
to this day I make one thing a pretty
good tuna fish sandwich and ramen
noodles that's I ate so many ramen
noodles that it changes the composition
of your body I could get yeah yeah your
blood becomes like a yellow broth that's
my ad for ramen noodles
it is pretty good though it's a pretty
good noodle it is a very good noodle
ramen noodles check it out when you have
a chance we're gonna get free noodles
now we're no saps I talked about
something else no no I know I should
have tell oh yeah no you were supposed
to mention Porsche that's what you're
supposed oh right that's that's what you
want three yeah instead we're like hey
we're gonna score some free Ronnie and
now we just sit back and wait for the
ramen to come
you